[Musique]
plus de poubelles plus de déchets dans
nos dépotoirs
en 2021 chaque Québécois a produit 716
kg de déchets loin de l'objectif de
réduction qui est de 525 kg pour 2023 la
constat qu'on fait c'est que la gestion
des matériaux au Québec demeurent un
défi un peu plus de 6 millions de tonnes
de déchets ont été envoyés dans des
sites d'enfouissement au Québec une
hausse de 5% par rapport à 2018 surtout
attribuable au secteur de la
construction et de la démolition les
mesures volontaires semblent avoir
atteint leur limite donc ça prend des
obligations des contraintes pour
s'assurer que les matériaux de
construction sont effectivement triés à
la source c'est un secteur auquel on
veut s'attarder davantage d'ailleurs un
comité d'experts qui a été mis en place
l'an dernier que le mandat de faire des
recommandations au ministre le recyclage
quant à lui fait partie des habitudes de
vie
[Applaudissements]
on envoie davantage de matières
recyclables dans les centres de tri le
contexte pandémique des achats en ligne
et des livraisons y est pour beaucoup
mais au final une plus grande quantité
est rejetée 24% de ce que vous mettez
dans votre bac n'est pas recyclé ce qui
est plus que dans le dernier bilan donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a régressé même au
niveau au niveau de la récupération du
recyclage turbo pas se permettre de
stagner c'est comme si on fait de la
bicyclette la biclette si on pas
on tombe en environnement c'est un petit
peu ça si on avance pas on tombe et là
on a reculé cette année avec le bilan la
lueur l'augmentation du compost de plus
en plus de municipalités ont implanté
des collègues de matières organiques de
résidus alimentaires donc ça ça fait en
sorte qu'on a davantage de matière qui
sont collectées peut soit devenir
quelque chose de très très bon ou
quelque chose de très mauvais ça dépend
dans quel bac on a la maison mais tous
s'entendables solution
s de Canada Montréal